what's your iq 120
91 and what does it all mean
is it even possible to define a person's
intelligence by a test
and does who is setting the test and why
make a difference to your score
welcome to this short guide to iq made
with the help of two
highly intelligent experts iq really
started with alfred binet
who was a frenchman and he was asked by
his government to develop a test
that could determine whether people
needed remedial help with their
education they later became
dubbed iq intelligent quotient but he
warned against that name because he said
they weren't
tests of intelligence what they were
were tests of a certain kind of ability
so
binet was the originator of intelligence
testing
and that led to the concept of iq
that we have today the idea that
somebody could have
a general intellectual level that could
be measured between one and a hundred
what happened next
was that it crossed the atlantic and was
adopted by
american psychologists and they decided
that iq was innate that you were born
with it
there was nothing you could do to change
it and the different population groups
different ethnic groups had different
innate iq
[Music]
this view of the early iq testers in the
united states has been subsequently
decisively disproved with ashkenazi jews
at the time of the first world war they
had lower than average iqs
by the time of the second world war
higher than average and the reason for
that
was they had they had better education
better nutrition
and that on average the parents had
become better educated as well
so those factors shifted the average iqs
the reason different groups
score differently on iq relates to the
fact that
iq tests measure abstract intelligence
in other words your ability to deal with
abstract logic
and that is determined very
significantly
by what happens in your early years of
your life so if you come from a
community
where there's a lot of argument where
you're encouraged to read
were you encouraged to discuss things on
average it's likely that that community
will have higher iqs iq tests have often
throughout history been used to
further political aims whether those be
sexist racist whatever agenda
politicians
may want to put forward iq tests have
been used
to support that and the idea that they
are
scientific because they're based on
quantitative measures
has been something that's been exploited
by many governments
iq tests in the early 20th century
sometimes women did
fair worse that wasn't always the case
intelligence tests
were based on completing activities such
as
completing a puzzle completing a task
looking at reaction times
and if someone had not engaged in those
activities before
if they were for example a girl that had
never been allowed to
access these kinds of activities they
wouldn't perform in the same way as
somebody who had done
one of the dangers of iq tests is that
they people see them
as a measure of intelligence whereas
really what they're measuring is
abstract logic
and there are other forms of
intelligence like emotional intelligence
like practical intelligence like
long-term memory like wisdom that they
don't measure
i'm not opposed to iq tests per se i
think that they are useful
in measuring abilities in things like
maths
science computer science because they're
measuring the same kinds of things that
iq tests measure
i think the biggest misconception of
about iq is that it's the same thing as
intelligence and it's not
we've seen that iq can change so
if you practice iq tests your iq will go
up
so environmental conditions and
education
can change iq it is not fixed i would
hope
that intelligence would never be used as
a concept
to make political decisions over whether
or not someone has
access to education access to healthcare
access to freedom of movement access to
any of these universal human rights
intelligence is a multifaceted thing and
multifaceted things
can't really be measured in terms of a
single number
which is what iq tests give you and
when they've looked at at the genetics
of intelligence
there are thousands of genes that are
implicated
so it is a much more complex thing than
what is measured
by a single iq test